so i have a few different absolutely
crazy things to catch you up on
uh relating to one of donald trump's
closest advisors kellyanne
conway kellyanne has announced that
she's going to be leaving the white
house at the end of the month meaning in
just a few days
because of a need to quote focus on the
family now if you're not aware
kellyanne conway has been just a
disgusting
trump sycophant for years but she
happens to be married to george conway
who is an anti-trump republican and who
in fact has become
one of the loudest anti-trump republican
voices on the internet
and part of this anti-trump republican
coalition called the lincoln project
well in the middle of all this
their daughter claudia conway became an
outspoken
anti-trump personality online
clearly things are really bad for the
family and so kellyanne conway has now
announced that she's leaving the white
house
george conway is leaving the lincoln
project and leaving twitter
and it seems that this clearly is the
right move for them as a family and part
of the constant
dysfunction of the trump white house has
just bled over and is ruining so
many people's lives and uh clearly
the decision made by the conway parents
must in part be because of
the insanity that their children have
been pulled into
kellyanne conway putting out a statement
saying about her and her husband that
quote
we disagree about plenty but we are
united on what matters most
the kids our four children are teens and
tweens
starting a new academic year in the
middle school in high school that will
be conducted remotely from home for at
least a few months
as millions of parents nationwide know
kids doing school from home
requires a level of attention and
vigilance that is as unusual as these
times
this is completely my choice and my
voice in time
i will announce future plans for now and
for my beloved children it will be less
drama and more mama their daughter
claudia
also tweeted over the weekend that she
was going to be taking a break from
twitter
and listen this all is a horrible
situation
but in the middle of this their
daughter in a now deleted video also
accused kellyanne conway of physical
abuse and again that video has since
been deleted
there have been notable twitter
exchanges between mom and daughter for
example when kellyanne tweeted
about herman cain quote herman cain led
a remarkable life and will be missed
he loved his family the country and the
lord he triumphed in business beat
cancer and was a voice for freedom
god bless you and yours herman her
daughter claudia conway responded
yes it is sad but wasn't your
administration complicit
in his death yikes so here's the bottom
line
i don't i don't know if kellyanne conway
abused her daughter
uh i i don't know anything about that
this is clearly a family
in struggle it should be up to them to
figure out what's best for the family
i'm less interested in the gossip
element and more interested in the theme
which is that everything trump touches
turns to manure
how many lives and i'm not talking about
you know you can talk about
millions of lives have been ruined by
donald trump's presidency
in terms of financial repercussions or
the friends and relatives of the people
who died of coronavirus who didn't have
to i'm not talking about that
i'm just saying people who work for
trump
the people trump brings around him the
number of ruined lives
people arrested people fired people
becoming global laughing stocks
kellyanne conway is the 557th person to
leave the trump administration since the
beginning
trump's sister recorded has been
recorded recently
saying horrible things about trump
trump's niece
wrote a devastating book about him
melania
is now reportedly recorded saying
horrible things about trump and his own
children which i'll talk about next
we just need a normal presidency and a
normal president and as i tweeted a
couple of days ago and it seemed to
resonate with a lot of people
joe biden's presidency if we get one
would probably be one of the most boring
in a very long time
and that's perfectly fine with me now as
parents
it does seem the conways realize
that this public battle where they've
been on opposite sides of this
presidency has been terrible for their
family and their kids
that's good i guess it's better that
they recognize that now
instead of in another six months we
could say but it would have been far
better for them to recognize that
three and a half years ago let's now
talk about the melania revelations